بوصفها اكبر مشروع تراثي حول العالم تتوزع
المتاحف التراثيه في حي طريف التاريخي في
الدرعيه هذا الممر يذهب بك الى متحف
الدرعيه الذي يغوص بك الى تاريخ طويل ممتد
لثلاث مئه سنه يعود بك الى تاريخ الدوله
السعوديه الاولى والثانيه والثالثه وابرز
محطاتها ورجالاتها واذا المقتنيات
المتواجده من خلال هذه الحقبه من السنوات
التي يتم عرضها في هذا المكان الكثير من
السوء الزوار الاف الزوار بداوا يتوافدون
الى هذا المتحف منذ شهر ونصف حيث افتتح
هذا المتحف همم
هذه زياره الاولى للسعوديه انا هنا منذ
حوالي يوم واحد وانا اتجول للتعرف على
تاريخ البلاد انا قادم من بريطانيا
وافكارنا عن المنطقه العربيه قليله هناك
افكار النمطيه عن كل دوله ولهذا السبب جئ
الى هنا للتعرف على التاريخ الحقيقي سيبقى
المملكه العربيه السعوديه حتى الان مدهشه
وقد احببتها كثيرا جئنا الى هنا للتعرف
على ثقافه البلاد وجذورها واصولها
ومنشاتها ولانها تقع بين وحتين فهذا يجعل
موقعها مهما جدا الى الان كل شيء كان
مثيرا جدا وكذلك رؤيه سيف الملك كان امرا
رائع
يحكي متحف الدرعيه عن اهلك الظروف وحتى
افضل لها التي مرت بها الدرعيه حصار
الدرعيه في الدوله السعوديه الاولى كان من
ابرز المحطات التي تحدث عنها بالاضافه الى
عرضه لبعض المقتنيات للمره الاولى ومنها
المدافع التي استخدمتها الدوله العثمانيه
همم التي هاجمت وحاصره الدرعيه في محاوله
لاسقاطها في همم ذلك الوقت
التجربه مثيره جدا لانني احب مشاهده
الاماكن الثقافيه مثل هذا لقد تعرفت على
الازياء وعلى التاريخ وكيف انشئت المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وكيف تطورت مع مرور
الزمن انها تجربه مسليه جدا ومثيره
بالنسبه لي في هذا الموقع هو اخر موقع في
متحف الدرعيه حيث يتم عرض ابرز القطع
واهمه التي توقف عندها الناس كثيرا لتصوير
تحدث عن السيف الاجرب ونسخه للطب نسخه طبق
الاصل من السيف الاجرب وهو سيف الامام
تركي بن عبد الله مؤسس الدوله السعوديه
الثانيه وكان احد ابرز واهم السيوف على
مستوى همم
القصائد
في تلك المنطقه او المرحله التاريخيه لهذا
الصيب بالاضافه الى عدد من مقتنيات الاخرى
يختم بها الزائر رحلته في متحف الدرعيه
الذي هو واحد من سته متاحه في اخرى في
طريف التاريخي تغوص بك بتاريخ الدرعيه حتى
من ناحيه الخيول العربيه الاصيله والتجاره
والنزول وغيرها من الرحله المتكامله لزائر
والسائح في الدرعيه